nominated the best performance by an
actress our Ellen Burstyn The Exorcist
Glenda Jackson for a touch of class
Marsha Mason for Cinderella liberty
Barbra Streisand for the way we were
Joanne Woodward for summer wishes winter
dreams here is the envelope and the
winner is Glenda Jackson
the Best Actress Award for Glenda
Jackson the producer of the touch of
class mr. Melvin Frank
I'm very very honored that Glenda has
asked me to accept this award for her
you have honored a very great lady as
well as a very great actress and I know
she'd be aware of our time problems here
and I know she'd be very short and
succinct and would ever think she has
I'm pretty sure she'd thank her director
she'd probably thank her producer and
she'd undoubtedly thank her writers and
it's two and a half of those fellas I'd
like to say Glenda you're welcome
and you're very welcome indeed and I
must congratulate you my fellow Academy
Award members in selecting this reading
magnificent woman this great lady for
this very great honor thank you very
much